the human story of technological
innovation is really the story of how we
exteriorize our imagination reycarts
while the futurist famously says that
our capacity to imagine to conceive of
what might be combined with our
modest-looking of thumbs with sufficient
touch you're in is literally a secondary
force of evolution called technology and
it will continue it is set until the
entire universe is at our fingertips
what is this impulse to innovate what is
this impulse to instantiate our
imagination the cognitive philosophers
David Chalmers and Andy Clark they
describe technology is literally a
scaffolding of mine the extended mind
right and we use this to extend our
thoughts our reach in our vision and it
has always been so right there is
historical precedent for this a hundred
thousand years ago when early humans
first picked up a stick on the ground we
use that stick that instrument to extend
our limits to reach a fruit on a really
high tree to overcome those things that
got in the way of us exercising our
agency and the uncanny almost
self-organizing miracle that we are
beholding as we witness this disruptive
age is that technology seems to have
taken on a life of its own technology is
imagination exteriorized technology is
our creativity literalized and what
exactly is going on why is everything
changing so fast well here is where it
gets really interesting enter port and
more the co-founder of Intel Corporation
who first picked up on something right
to understand is to perceive patterns he
realized that technological progress was
counter intuitive to how human beings
think about change we are linear
thinkers but we live in an exponential
world technology changes at an
exponential rate and so we're future
blind it's counterintuitive to our
intuition we never see the future coming
because our innovations seem to be
accelerating and what does it mean what
is exponential change what is what he
coined Moore's law appears
example Ray Kurzweil talks about 30
steps if you take 30 linear steps 1 2 3
4 5 you get to 30 that's linear change
over time that's our intuition if you
take the same amount of steps
exponentially in 30 steps you get to a
billion 30 linear steps gets you to 30
30 exponential steps gets you to a
billion this is the reason why the
smartphone in your pocket today is a
million times cheaper a million times
smaller and a thousand times more
powerful than what used to be a 60
million dollar supercomputer that was
half a building in size 40 years ago so
understand this understand Moore's law
this second law of nature this
technological impulse towards self
organization what Kevin Kelly from Wired
magazine labeled the Technium the
seventh kingdom of life subjects the
same evolutionary forces as biological
evolution technology comes through us
but not from us and though it is with us
it belongs not to us it is a scaffolding
of mind
it is the exteriorization of human
imagination it is imagination
literalized this is the human machine
civilization moving us towards an event
horizon where we literally moved into
our own imaginations